I saw this story on The Daily Mail Chris
Cuomo dramatically reveals he was going
to quote kill everybody including myself
after he was fired from CNN things can
consume you he says I had to accept the
CNN termination because I was going to
kill everybody including myself things
can consume you now the first thing I'm
gonna throw everybody down a flight of
stairs well so look look my first
assumption is he's just it's a turn of
phrase he means like oh you know I'm
gonna show them he's not literally
saying it but then when he said
including myself I'm like okay he's
actually talking about seriously hurting
people because he got fired Jimmy is
just laughing I remember when Chris came
out of the basement when they said I've
been in his son and he starts lying he's
like I haven't even left the house in
however long and his son's like watching
him lie right in front of his face I
would imagine that would make someone
depressed to have to lie in front of
your son so Tim if you or I launched a
news report as fallacious as Chris
Cuomo's basement exit
we would be laughed out of the business
forever like we that's the thing people
pretend you and I do and that's the
stuff that CNN actually does on the
regular he did a complete fake phony
thing that he was staying in his
basement because of kovid it turned out
he was out of his house all the time he
got into a fight with some guy out on
his front lawn and a different property
yeah at a different property and then he
when he comes out of the basement his
family's sitting around there going yeah
they're they're all going along with the
lie as if he just came out for the first
time it gets revealed that's a lie they
never it's nothing nothing's like a blip
it's like a it's like a chemical fire in
Palestine Ohio nobody knows about him
that's right yeah the Palestinians they
tend to get a bad arrest have a secret
Palestine Palestinians I guess you would
call uh yeah and honestly that Chris
Cuomo video everyone should check that
out again for reference at some point
because you got to see his son's face
while he's lying his son knows he's
lying on television and to do that to
your kid right that's a that's child
abuse that's psychological torture to
that kid and now his kid knows the news
is fake everything's fake he said his
kids call him fake news remember he told
that story I'm pretty sure it was him he
said his kids would would make fun of
him call him fake news when they were
mad at him so how come he didn't get
fired for that that's the weirdest thing
hold on because that's CNN's Mo that's
right you know he was doing what he was
supposed to do yeah he was creating
drama and that's what they do at CNN
it's not a news show it's a drama show
Zucker was running the show and he's The
Apprentice guy he's the NBC reality TV
show guy so CNN starts falling apart and
they say let's bring in the uh reality
TV show style stuff and do that instead
now it's funny to see Chris Cuomo losing
his mind and to see how deranged he he
is and was now you got the story about
Don Lemon but isn't it comforting Tim to
know that guy's like uh Cuomo Chris
Cuomo are barely keeping it together
that they're suffering isn't that
they're thinking about Kiva thought
about killing myself and lately but not
everybody else right I don't know I
think it's a bad thing I think it's a
bad thing but he's an evil guy if he'd
been put through it and came out was
like what have I done I want to die
that's different than actively lying and
then now I understand why he would feel
that way because he's like he's ashamed
well this doesn't feel like sadness it
feels like anger right like this
shouldn't have been done to me and it's
like exactly if you saw any High School
shoot or Manifesto and they're like this
kid said he wanted to shoot everyone and
himself they'd be like lock that kid up
immediately right you guys ever on
Futurama Bender is depressed and he's
like oh I'm so depressed I wish everyone
else was dead it's that that's the
mentality that his life falls apart and
he is of that psychotic mindset where
it's kind of a shocking uh Revelation to
admit so you know props to him but I
think what you see here is the kind of
personality that is required to get jobs
at these companies because what I want
to say about CNN
it's not uh like YouTube let's let's
talk about uh you know me and Jimmy we
make YouTube channels we do the grind we
do the work we make the channel and then
people come and eventually gather around
you build an audience CNN is an ivory
Tower and to open the door there is a
lord who says you will do as you're told
and the guy says I will say and do
anything if you let me climb to the top
of this Tower that's the kind of person
CNN attracts Psychopathic narcissists
who then talk about how they wanted to
hurt other people because they lost
their keys to the Ivory Tower right and
nothing is just laughing every time he
is right you think they do it
incrementally like take your shoes off
before you come in and they're like now
take your pants off before you go to the
second floor I'm not your shirt take it
all off or but then
but then the higher they get up in every
Tower they're like oh I deserve to be
here like I deserve that show I should
be able to punish people around me who
Took My Job away from me it's it's such
a strange way to behave they did a study
uh and I'm gonna butcher it but
basically the the end of the study was
the conclusion was they gave people like
they were playing Monopoly and they gave
somebody way more money to start with
and then even if that person won at the
end they thought they deserved to win
they thought they did play better yeah
even though did you have you heard about
that yeah yeah so that's what you're
that's what you kind of talking about so
if you get that job in corporate media
and you ascend to the to the height of
it you think that you earned it and you
deserve it what it what it really
indicates is that you're the you're the
perfect tool to serve the oligarchy and
that's who gets promoted in that because
if you go against them you get fired
like Phil Donahue when he's they fired
him when he was against the Iraq War he
had the number one Show on MSNBC and
they fired him and they said it was
because of low ratings they had the
highest rated show at the time on the
network and then a memo came out that
got released right leaked and it said
because he was an anti-war and that was
bad for our advertising wow Bill Maher
also yeah I was gonna say what happened
with Bill though how do you claws way
back in because he has oh so here's the
story I heard I don't know if it's true
the story I heard was that his manager
also did a supreme channels so HBO
wanted Sopranos and his manager being a
good manager strong armed them and said
well you got to take Bill too and so
that's how that's what I heard I don't
know if that's 100 True or 50 that's the
story I heard in Hollywood yeah Bill uh
what was it he on politically incorrect
he criticized the Iraq and Afghan
Afghanistan war so what he said was that
the terrorists who flew the bill the
planes into the buildings on 9 11 were
not cowards and you couldn't say that he
said well they didn't they weren't
cowards they were they killed they
risked their own life to do this thing
they believed in they weren't power you
can't say that that's crazy yeah see I
mean that's that's the old school cancel
culture that the corporate overlords
demanded you fall in line or else that's
right now they have a harder time with
that so now they go the censorship route
and they try and block you from the back
end so exactly this isn't the first time
that they've been afraid you know
newspapers were afraid of television
news right and they tried to demonize
television news as radicalizing people
which is exactly what happened so when
shows like yours and mine and others
become popular we get audiences on
YouTube while we're stealing their
audience from The New York Times CNN and
the Washington Post and so then they
start to write that's how the
adpocalypse all started they started
they noticed that they were losing their
audience to plea people like us so they
write these crazy hit pieces that say
that YouTube is radicalizing children to
be Nazis and pedophiles and white
supremacists and right Wingers and all
this stuff and people are like oh and
that's why all of a sudden overnight
they dropped all their advertising on
YouTube overnight that happened and
that's and why did they do that because
we're actually a threat to them and so
now we have all these rules of how we
can talk and how we'll and it's you know
the old saying is who you can't
criticize rules over you well we can't
criticize the covet narrative in the way
it deserves to be on YouTube and who
owns that that's big Pharma so you can't
big Pharma has captured the FDA big
Pharma has captured the CDC but uh fauci
is a psychopathological liar and
criminally corrupt that's why he's been
able to have that job for 43 years and
he's the highest paid person in
government he makes almost a half a
million dollars a year in government you
know how much money that is that's like
10 grand a week they pay him that's 40
Grand a month remember when the left was
concerned about massive multinational
corporations like big Pharma and would
call out big Pharma specifically for
like I don't know the fines they've had
to pay over the criminal actions they've
taken but now for some reason you know
where I'm going with this yes what what
happened so people who have new young
people came up in Allegiance these
people who I know all my life who are
supposed to be critical and skeptical of
big business and big Pharma and Military
they have they have question authority
bumper stickers and then they shame you
if you question the authority on coven
it's like you what is going on people
who still think that we haven't landed
on the moon don't want you to question
the kovic narrative it's the craziest
thing I don't know what happened but
everybody I know who were the biggest
cynics comedians they lost their
cynicism they lost their healthy sense
of skepticism about people who we've
always known were the biggest corrupt
criminals in the world team you know
that I mean when I say criminals I mean
did they put Asbestos and baby powder
and then sell it to poor people after
they got yes that's the kind of
they did I mean they put aged tainted
stuff and blood and send it to poor
countries yes they did they gave people
hey did they did they give sell you
heart medicine they knew it was going to
give you a heart attack yes they knew it
and they did it anyways so what would be
any different than now it turns out
nothing except they oh I'm sorry
effing nothing but they have more
control of the media how much has a they
made a hundred billion dollars off of
covid that's it fun one company Pfizer
made 100 billion dollars off of covet do
you know how much the entire recorded
music industry makes in the United
States 12 billion dollars a year 12
billion every every record everything
that's how much they made off of one
covid so demand you know what kind of
power that gives you that gives you the
power to buy every person in the media
which they did they and they bought
everybody in the government which they
did they just got in California which is
super majority Democrat with a Democrat
Governor they'd passed a law telling
doctors they're not allowed to practice
medicine that goes against what big
Pharma says when it comes to covid and
if they do they're going to get fined
that's what they're so they're taking
the ability to practice medicine away
from doctors because they're so
corrupted
yep I mean that's the end of the show
everyone thanks for coming that's just
the beginning we've been lied to about
covid on a scale that our brains can't
even comprehend and people are just now
starting to comprehend well let's talk
about the media so I I hate to actually
talk about some of these people because
they don't deserve the attention but you
worked with The Young Turks for a long
time
and uh I've I've known them for a bit
and the interesting thing is that it's
not just the corporate press that we
we've seen all of a sudden look we know
that everything's brought to you by
Pfizer we know the Unholy satanic
dancing or whatever performance was
brought to you by Pfizer we know that
all these talk shows are brought to you
by five yeah I get it but what happened
to Independent Media Outlets like The
Young Turks where all of a sudden they
went from being the counterculture to
Towing the line for the establishment I
just think Trump happened and so they
became you're either with us or against
us and they were they didn't want to be
on the outside it's cold thinking now to
be a Democrat and a democratic voter
it's a cult thinking like right now
um no I I I I criticize the Democrats
because I was a Democrat my whole life
up until 2016 when they cheated Bernie
in the primary and then Bernie didn't
make him pay a price for it and not only
that he didn't make them reform right
they still have super delegates they
still take corporate money they still do
all that stuff that screwed him and
he'll never use his leverage to so I
stopped being a Democrat and so it's
very cult-like thinking people are
afraid to push back and have a different
thought and if you do it's like you're
oh you're one of them so everything
you're either with us or against us it's
very tribal thinking and it leads to the
country we have where half the country
can't afford a 500 emergency and people
are living under every bridge and we
still are told to hate our neighbor
we're told that our neighbor is the
cause of our problem even though the
establishment that a controlled
demolition of our economy which crushed
everybody except for a handful of
millionaires and they want me to be
angry because of the pain I'm feeling
don't be angry at my neighbor because he
wouldn't take a vaccine that didn't work
the way they said it did in the first
place and so I'm not gonna blame my
neighbor for that what I'm gonna do is
love my neighbor and I'm gonna find
common ground with my neighbor because
we have it and that's what scares the
hell out of the oligarchy is that if we
don't come if we come together and
realize we have a common enemy what's
like we're going to do on Sunday at this
anti-war rally people of all political
stripes are coming together to oppose
the military-industrial complex which
has been fleecing this country for at
least the last 30 years what what is
this rally uh specifically is about
Ukraine and or what and let me just say
for YouTube the vaccine is safe and
effective and it certainly does stop it
slowed the transmission and contraction
it'll keep you from getting seriously
ill or hospitalized and talk to a doctor
about it right after about what's
sponsored by
fill in the blank no no in all
seriousness talk to a doctor you know
and by you know the vaccine is so good
my heart swells with pride you got the
vaccine with pride yes and you got it
you told me you got injured I did I did
get a vaccine injury and that that's
what led to me becoming uh that like
whatever are you public about have you
been public about the whole process and
like whatever the whole thing yeah I
talked all about it what happened and so
I just got sick and I couldn't get
better uh I had why don't why don't we
why don't we talk about this um yeah we
go deep later we'll go deep on this one
because I think if
I I think much to the point of many
people but I think if we really want to
go Crank It Up to 11. we'll uh we'll
we'll talk over okaycast.com become a
member let's do that and uh for now I
think that story in and of itself is
interesting so we'll we'll Cruise back
to uh uh 30 000 feet and I'll ask you
this is what snapped you out of it or
like made you realize the media is lying
or what
uh you mean about kovid well like you
know what was your what was your moment
where you were like holy crap these
people are full of it
oh I mean you've probably always felt
I've always felt pressed well I've
always told that about the corporate
press but then I didn't understand was
what happened with Trump is that people
like
um you know and it wasn't just tyt but
that was the people that were I was a
part of right and they just became the
opposite of what they're supposed to be
right they're supposed to push back
against the corporate narrative even
when it you know if it's somebody that
they hate against Trump you're supposed
to tell the truth and they wouldn't do
it and they just kept repeating CA and
FBI talking points about everything
including Julian Assange which was
disgusting as they were you know I'm
debunking the articles about
Julian Assange and Paul manafort
visiting him at the embassy in London
even though they don't have any pictures
of it I'm debunking that in their Studio
they come on after me and they push that
story so so you're at The Young Turks
and you're like this is a lie and then
20 minutes later they're like actually
it's true no this is 100 true I know but
I couldn't my jaw was on the floor when
they did that thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time